I made a crazy risky gamble to pay
alright awesome thank you so much for
being here this film is relentlessly
aggressive and awesome in in so many
different ways you know Adam let me
start with you I can only imagine just
the headspace to get into this guy's
kind of kind of mind was that difficult
for you was it exhausting at the end of
the day playing this dude yeah I guess I
guess it was sometimes but it was it was
thought out these guys thought out
everything they wanted me to know every
possible Avenue to go in that day and
they discussed we had so much
pre-production and discussions that we
were ready to go and it was just and it
was just off to the races yeah yeah I
remember I mean there were some days
that was a knockout punch at the end of
the day but everybody was in it together
we all were feeling the same energy
Julia for a first film first feature
film for you it's gotta be like the
craziest first first feature to do yeah
very surreal talked about the experience
and I and I heard something like we that
they discovered you the satis on
Instagram is that true yeah well it was
vine and I used to make like really cool
videos on vine and I think that Josh saw
them and was like oh me like who is that
and then we had mutual friends so
through them we kind of met and that was
probably like six years ago
and then probably like five years ago
they started talking to me about this
role and ever since then Josh is just
like really pushed for me to be in it
and then of course you know when the
bigger Studios got involved they wanted
a real actress and and they wanted the
big names but I did a screen test and
and mine was better than everyone what
is is that screen test just you guys
like physically yeah I think they just
wanted to see like the chemistry and it
was mostly just improv they wanted to
see just how we went back and forth and
and I think we just really get along and
he's hilarious and I think I'm pretty
funny too and and we just went back and
forth and the energy was amazing and it
really showed a few days yeah yeah and
then we had one where it was karaoke and
I had to sing to him yeah
and for that one I was a little nervous
I think Chris Isaak yeah and then I
think we did also Kid Rock and Sheryl
Crow we added it yeah I'm saying back
yeah boys
you wouldn't think so looking at him but
he doesn't do a bad she does not do a
bad take every single take is just
incredible yeah and it was so great to
have him it's like you know like a
mentor in no way don't get guys but it
was it was like you know I was learning
from him so you know I was like you know
just really paying attention to
everything he did and trying to channel
it the best together yeah yeah it
definitely is unexpected I think there's
a lot of unexpected things about this
Idina kind of love that that frozen to
and uncut gems are coming out within a
couple of weeks of each other I don't I
don't necessarily think I'm gonna
recommend that double feature to a lot
of people but this is unlike any you
know talk about big and and and who did
you look at did you look at like wives
of like diamond district guys like who
look like I grew up in Long Island I
know I'm not all on attitude so you knew
that you know these people
and I just yeah I did some some research
with the guys just to understand really
where they wanted these people to come
from and everything but most it was just
like you know doing the dance and being
in the moment without him for the most
part in thinking back to some of that
history of Long Island yeah you know
what Keith oh I'd love to talk to you
about safdie's process you know I think
so many of these scenes it's just like I
said relentless and it's just chaotic
you know and and what is that like when
you're shooting it like a scene like in
the jewelry store where there's like 15
16 people around and it's just
chaotically moving around is do you feel
that chaos on set or is it a lot
organized chaos oh yes of course it's
controlled chaos but it's unlike any
experience I've had I'm gonna say yeah
where it's just I don't know sort of its
kind of feels more like life you know
and the way I view life I run very
anxious so it's constantly always
feeling like things are moving and
spiraling out of control so but that
makes me feel like a player in the game
of the set in a way that I feel in life
you know it's constantly just decision
making and that's the same thing you're
doing on set so it kind of just just
translates you know as life and then it
makes a unique experience it's better I
think we can be neurotic so it gets us
out of our head and we can just like
roll with the punches of you know where
the chaos is there we can just kind of
stay out you know stop judging ourselves
and just be instrument is everything
scripted or are they like this is what's
happening in the scene just go berserk
on each other I think it's it's scripted
and that with with freedom mm-hmm
you let you let things happen and come
out of what is good I also do a variety
of takes like you know sometimes I'll be
like all right now more scripted or it
would be like just do whatever the [ __ ]
on this when we got it like just yes
yeah I was thinking about there's a
fight between that that you guys have
that spills out into the street and
inside a cab and it's just so wild that
felt 35 percent scripted the other 65
Julian just took she's yeah I meet with
some stuff yeah yeah they kind like I I
don't know I had my vision as to how I
wanted the scene to go and what I wanted
to say and I I told them that you know
and they were kind of like no can you
say that and I was like no this is how
the scene is gonna go and and I did it
and it kind of just like took on a life
of its own and at that point it was kind
of guiding me you know like yeah and
yeah I got really into it felt very real
difference between theater and film I
will say you don't get to change the
lines yeah it must be really hard it's a
super intense movie do you have any
advice for movie goers before they go to
the theater anything that they should do
to prepare to watch this oh just come
you wring their eyes mop um whatever
their heart medicine just come prepared
you